[Music]
it's et social study what stars are
posting online it's really nice you know
we can be together Bella Hadid finally
crossed paths with ex the weekend for
the first time since he was spotted
kissing Selena Gomez the two attended a
memorial concert at Madison Square
Garden in honor of the late ASAP yams
[Applause]
Ariana Grande wished boyfriend Mac
Miller
a happy 25th birthday with this
hilarious snapchat video of the two
dancing in the car the singer captioned
the sweet clip I love you with all my
heart
next flip or flop star Tarek el Moussa
clears up rumors about his split from
Christina Tariq spoke out on social
media writing I will keep my focus on
what matters most which is co-parenting
our children and working hard on our
business I'm happy though meanwhile blac
Chyna's besties Amber Rose spent some
quality time cuddling with her daughter
dreams an Audrina Patridge is back to
brunette at the request from diehard
heels fans you still don't know what's
what are you doing what we just accepted
talk to you first
finally Steve Carell cruel joke for the
office fans the actor took to Twitter
writing breaking news the office
returning to NBC but the excitement was
short-lived
moments later Steve tweeted wait sorry I
meant Will and Grace typos and joked he
was had by toby flenderson
[Music]
you